we have returned yes indeed we are back
and there's so much to talk about from
Harvey Weinstein to a New York Times
op-ed that targeted The Daily wire last
Thursday night plus we will be talking
about sergeant Bowe Bergdahl who just
pleaded guilty to desertion and what
that says about the Obama
administration's honesty problems I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
so once again there will be no
Disneyland for anyone I came back and
that things remain just as bad as when I
left and in some ways worse so thanks
for that
appreciated everyone well done we will
get to all of the news there's plenty to
talk about for Shore ranging from Harvey
Weinstein i-i've not been able to give
my breakdown on the Harvey Weinstein
scandal because that actually broke
after I left for a vacation but I have a
lot of thoughts on that that go to sort
of what Hollywood is all about and what
needs to happen if you don't want Harvey
Weinstein's to be the future of the
industry I also want to talk about some
good moves that President Trump made
while I was away plus I will definitely
have some comments that I'm gonna begin
with about this New York Times op-ed
that targeted me personally and also
targeted the Daily wire but before we do
any of that first I want to say thank
you to our sponsors over at ring.com so
Rings mission is to make a neighborhood
safer the way that people tend to break
into homes is they bring the doorbell
and they see if you're home and then if
you don't pick up then they feel like
okay I can break into the house and no
one's gonna stop me well that is why
ring video doorbell is an amazing
amazing invention they know that home
security begins at the front door the
way that it works is that you ring the
doorbell and it automatically it
automatically goes to your phone so I
can be on vacation in Hawaii and I can
pick up the doorbell and make it seem as
though I am home I can also call the
police I set off an alarm from my from
my phone and so bring videos where I
make sure that my house is safe even
when I am not there but that's not where
security ends right now they have a new
level of security they've added to the
rest of your home with the ring
floodlight cam and just like the
doorbell it's a motion-activated camera
and floodlight that connects right to
your phone with HD video and two-way
audio that lets you know the moment
anyone steps on your property you can
see and speak to visitors and set off an
alarm right from your phone and again
when things go bump in the night because
of the floodlight cam you will know who
it is where they are on your property
and all the rest it offers the in of the
ultimate in home security with those
high visibility floodlights and a
powerful HD camera that puts security in
your hands
save up to one hundred and fifty dollars
off that ring of security kit when you
go to ring comm slash Ben that's
ring.com
/ Ben again that's ring comm / Ben and
you get one hundred and fifty bucks off
a ring of security kit when you use that
/ Ben at the end so again ring
come / Ben that also lets them know that
we set you okay so apparently all hell
broke loose
last week and I was off for the last
three days of the week I want to start
by responding to this op eds I've gotten
a lot of mail about it while I was out
and there was a full op-ed in the New
York Times coming after me personally as
well as The Daily wire from a woman
named Jane Coates
Jane Koston Jane Koston obviously I
don't know her work very well so I can't
speak to the rest of her work but
basically the idea was that I am somehow
a guy who only panders to the right and
this is the hallmark of the write these
days is just pandering to the right what
I do know from Jane Koston is that she
is a lefty she's a liberal and and Jane
Koston has written pieces like this one
from MTV News titled quote on the
punching of Nazis subtitle I support it
this is back in January said if a Nazi
is in your presence can you ever punch
the Nazi in the god dang face the answer
is simple of course you can and then she
says that should you yes yes you should
you should punch Nazis in the god dang
face you should do so repeatedly if you
see more Nazis you should punch them too
so she sounds like a very tolerant and
the first individual which is just
wonderful and she titled her piece on me
the hollow bravery of ben shapiro so the
first thing is that i would just like to
note here i have never called myself
brave in fact i don't really consider
myself brave because i reserved that
title for law enforcement you know
people who put themselves in harm's way
to protect others i'm a guy who goes on
campus and i give talks and i have
security and i'm probably the safest guy
in the room as i've said in a thousand
interviews so for me
my job is not about bravery my job is
about saying things that i think are
true and then you take them or you leave
them you know the idea that I have ever
proclaimed that I am the hallmark of
bravery is just absurd but the piece
itself is really designed to attack the
entire conservative movement and and me
is sort of a supposed thought leader in
it so here is what Jane Koston writes
rights ben shapiro the conservative
writer prides himself on speaking bold
truths illiberal power his shtick goes
something like this set up a speech in a
progressive Bastion ideally a college
campus full of coastal elites who have
never left their bubble spar with
snowflakes who are offended by something
he says about race or gender or perhaps
even believe in
should have been invited in the first
place post the exchange on the internet
and use it as proof that the cultural
consensus is stacked dramatically
against conservatives as mr. Shapiro's
put it the left has run out of
aggressors to target instead they've
become the aggressors self-righteous
morality police dedicated to wiping out
- sensing thought well the reason I say
that is because Berkeley like the
University of California run by Janet
Napolitano a Democrat staffed entirely
by Democrats at the highest level
decided that I needed six hundred police
officers in order to speak at Berkeley
as I've said again 1,000 times the year
before I showed up with no security they
had my security team but there were no
police officers necessary it's not me
that's making this issue on campus it is
not I I am not the one who is who's
designing these problems on college
campuses nor do I even like them I mean
you can talk to people from my team they
will tell you before we do every lecture
I say I really hope this one is nice and
calm and as far as the idea that I don't
want to have people in the room with
whom I can discuss I've been debating
people on the left for a long time here
I mean I debated Cinque agar like two
maybe three months ago I debated a panel
of people including the n-double-a-cp
president in Spokane Washington and
Charles Moody
from the Seattle stranger when I was up
in Seattle I debated Shama savant who
was the who is the socialist city
council member in Seattle I'm going to
have a discussion with Sam Harris with
whom I strenuously disagree on religion
I'm gonna have a discussion with him up
in San Francisco in December in fact I'm
hard pressed to think of many people on
the right who debate people on the left
more than I do like high-ranking people
on the left more than I do I debated
Sally cone last year like I debate
people on the left all the time this
idea that I'm out there looking for
snowflakes to melt is just patently
absurd in fact I've said in my own
lectures I said in the Berkeley lecture
I believe I said that the easiest thing
in the world is to find some college
leftist to trigger but that's not my job
my job is to say things I think are true
in front of audiences full of leftists
and conservatives I wish more people who
are on the Left would show up I mean I
always have a standing rule look at
every one of my lectures for the last
year and a half I have a standing rule
if you disagree with me raise your hand
and go to the front of the line that is
my standing rule the idea that I'm not
out there trying to convert people that
I'm not out there trying to do outreach
that all I care about is the viral
videos that come
these exchanges it's just like there's
no evidence to this whatsoever in any
case Jane Coates Koston says quote it's
true the campuses tend to be hostile
places to conservatives like mr. Shapiro
charles murray and heather mcdonald but
the notion that there are the cultural
underdogs is bogus
really we're not the cultural underdogs
heather mcdonald and charles murray
aren't the cultural underdogs when
charles murray went to Middlebury
College a leftist professor I think
broke her collarbone thanks to the
students over there Charles Moreau who's
just shut down again over the weekend
we're not the cultural underdogs have
you seen the culture you might have you
might say we're not the political
underdogs I think that there that's that
sort of true I mean Berkeley I am the
political underdog but across the
country I don't think I am because I
think that the vast majority of people
agree with most of what I have to say
but the notion that we're not cultural
underdogs is absurd is what mr. Shapiro
does on campuses shadowboxing meant to
pander to his conservative fans whose
values dominate mainstream American
culture okay no evidence that that
conservative values dominate mainstream
American culture in fact virtually all
of the evidence is on the other side on
all of the major social issues of the
day without perhaps aside from abortion
there's no question that there is a
leftist / liberal consensus on cultural
issues
she said if he wants to be genuinely
brave he challenged some of the
wrongheaded ideas held by his right-wing
fans instead he uses his megaphone
that's it the website the daily where to
reinforce what they already believe okay
a couple of things here the idea that I
don't challenge wrongheaded ideas held
by some of my fans again you have to be
ignorant of my work in order to say this
fully ignorance of my work in order to
say this for the last two years I've
taken a very controversial position with
regard to president Trump who less Jane
Koston forget is rather popular among
people who support me I was the
initiator of good from Bad Trump I
created good from bad Trump right I am
the guy who had on my desk for months a
shoe we called it the put it on the
other foot shoe right we we actually
took this shoe and when Trump will do
something I would say put the shoe on
the other foot imagine Obama did it and
then let's try and see whether this is
something that's good or not I've been
very critical not only of President
Trump but I wrote a piece this morning
about why it's bad for a bunch of Magha
had
dummies to shut down a liberal speaker
left to speaker Xavier Becerra the
Attorney General of California over at
Whittier College and the idea that I
don't criticize people on the so-called
right side of the aisle is patently
absurd again I've criticized the
alt-right incessantly repeatedly when I
left Breitbart I criticized Steve Bannon
I criticized Steve Danon when he was
appointed to the to the campaign this I
don't know where she's getting this but
all I will say is that it is utterly in
disconnect with reality and anybody who
watches the show knows that that is the
case anybody who listens to the show
knows this is the case we try to be
intellectually honest about our
conservatism it seems to me that what
Jane Koston really wants is for me to be
on the left this is the same critique
that I heard from a lot of people on the
Left who didn't like the nevertrump
Republicans cuz they said why don't you
just vote for Hillary because Hillary's
awful okay change just because I
disagree with some people on the right
about things doesn't mean I have to
agree with your crappy point of view hey
if your if your idea of dissent is that
I have to agree with you then I dissent
from your dissent okay no I think you're
wrong I think that most of the stuff
that you write is wrong and guess what I
can do that maybe the reason I disagree
with you is because I think you're wrong
so what does she uses the example of us
pandering so she picks one example right
this one example that has been used by
the left over the last week when I was
on vacation and so on as she says on
Monday The Daily wire published a video
that depicted Native Americans is
animated savages before the arrival of
Christopher Columbus and one slide the
video list Native American achievements
as consisting of dreamcatchers tomahawks
and cannibalism while stating the
Columbus's arrival in 1492 assured the
arrival of math and the iPhone and then
she says the animated video is actually
the second one The Daily wire posted
this past weekend on the subject the
other carry the sub subtle title quote
Christopher Columbus actually was a
great man so the second video I think is
actually quite good the second video is
from Michael moles and it is a full
breakdown of the entire history of
Christopher Columbus it is full of
information
Koston of course just takes it for
granted the Christopher Columbus was a
bad guy so I'm sure she didn't even
bother to watch the video which is
chock-full of references to actual
primary documentation you should go
watch Knowles's video it has over a
million hits it is quite good the other
video I didn't like it didn't meet
editorial standards I was on vacation as
soon as I found out about it I wanted to
pull it down it was a satire video so I
wanted to you know I I was conflicted
in the sense that I don't like pulling
down satire I think that satire you get
a broader range than just you would in a
normal video and so I made the mistake
of leaving it up for 24 hours over that
24 hours I became increasingly
disconcerted with the video I really was
not a fan of it at the beginning
over the next 24 25 hours I really
watched it a few more times and found
that it crossed the lines for me that I
didn't want crossed and I took it down
and I issued an apology personally for
the video being on the site in the first
place which is as far as I'm aware what
you are supposed to do when a bad video
goes up on your site so okay if I if I
really wanted to not take off my right
wing fans I would have left the thing up
wouldn't I
and then Koston spends the next like
three paragraphs talking about not the
daily wire but the federalists the the
site run by a friend of mine pens
domenech and she talks about this the
the daily the the federalists pandering
to the right forgetting of course that
the federalists has run a number of
pieces disagreeing on major issues with
other members of the right that the
federalist has a pretty wide variety of
opinion mary katharine ham who was a
never Trumper is on that site so smiley
Hemingway who's a very Pro Trump writer
is on that site and then what she uses
her example of real pandering she said
that publication had a black crime tag
on its website until two weeks ago which
included an article titled if you don't
want police to shoot you don't resist
arrest and and so a couple of things on
that number one black crime tags tags
you know most of the editors that I cite
don't know that the tag is there right a
tag is an HTML thing it's not like every
single story gets filed away as a black
crime story there's a tag that somebody
in the backend is hitting that puts the
HTML in black crime for this site now I
don't think there should be a black
crime tag neither to the federalists
which is why they removed it okay but
again this whole idea here is that
conservatives are just catering to their
base now what I love about this article
is that Jane Koston is catering to her
left to space in the New York Times so
this entire article is not a rebuke to
anyone on the left it's not her speaking
truth to power on the left it's not her
saying to the left that people like me
should be able to speak at Berkeley no
instead it's Jane Koston pandering to
her own leftist readers and then
accusing us of doing that to our
right-wing readers and then what she's
really upset of course about is that
I am not on the left so she says that I
believe that transgender people have
mental illness and then she says that's
just terrible
okay have I been unclear about my
perspective on this there's a video of
me that's been seen 35 million times
talking about this
like literally 35 million times so I've
not been unclear about this and she
finishes up by saying I reached out to
mr. Shapiro to ask him about the
Columbus Day video she did and I emailed
her back the statement which we had
already put out or were putting out at
the time and then I added a one-line
comment said he sends over a statement
apologizing for its hang and engaged in
broad-based stereotyping which he also
posted on Twitter in the email he added
quote I think there's a lot of political
grounds be gained in pandering to your
own side and confirming their biases I
strive not to do that and then she
finishes and yet he and vast swaths of
the conservative right who decry
groupthink still do to tell strident
college students to examine their own
politics and embrace real debate is
brave to insist on the same from those
on the right would be even more
courageous um again she does not watched
a single speech I have ever done on the
right not one I guarantee you she has
not watched a single speech I've done on
campus if she has then I don't know if
she had the mute on but that is patently
crazy okay the idea that I have not told
college students on the right to examine
their own politics half of my speech at
Berkeley was devoted to why the
alt-right is stupid and why identity
politics of the right is bad and why if
you think that Mexico and China are
responsible for your lost job you are
probably wrong okay so again all of this
is just done all of this is just done
but it demonstrates something that I
think is more important and that is that
the left is so concerned with finding
enemies that they will find enemies
everywhere and I want to expand on that
and talk about who the real enemies to
public discourse are the people who are
really pandering to the base in just a
second but first I want to say thank you
to our sponsors over at the US
concealed-carry Association so all the
time you hear stories about some guy
breaking into somebody's house and the
hero homeowner shoots the guy good for
the homeowner somebody breaks into your
house threatens your family you should
shoot them but you never hear the rest
of the story the rest of the stories
usually the police come they question
the person at the very least the guy
spends the night in jail or at least
spend some time with the police well you
need to know what to do in order to
protect yourself and also what to do
when the police show up and that's why
you need the 2017 concealed carry and
family defense guide from the u.s.
concealed carry Association
is 100% free in it you will learn how to
detect attackers before they see you
how to survive a mass shooting the
safest and most dangerous places sit in
a restaurant how to responsibly own and
store a gun particularly if you have
small children as I do and a whole lot
more its 164 pages chock full of useful
material for you and your family they
have a bonus audio version so you can
listen in your car as well it's a
hundred percent free again and for a
limited time you get a bonus home
defense checklist as well so you can go
through and make sure that your family
is safe go to defend my family now calm
right now for a hundred percent free
instant access
that's defend my family now calm again
defend my family now calm defend my
family now calm go over and check it out
make sure your family is safe so here is
the point here people on the right
should never expect that folks on the
true left people who are intellectually
dishonest are going to grant them credit
for speaking truth to their own side
because it's not going to happen if you
tick off the left enough they're just
going to accuse you of pandering to your
own base that's all that's going to
happen it doesn't matter what you
actually say it doesn't matter what you
actually do it doesn't matter whether
you've gone out of your way to try and
be intellectually honest about your own
perspective or whether you've criticized
people on your supposing on the side
none of that matters to the left because
for the left
they must paint a picture of
right-wingers as a bunch of red meat
throwing red meat eating zombies who
simply want to consume information that
they like you know they don't worry
about that on their own side but they
worry about that on the right never mind
the fact that most conservatives read
things on the left most conservatives
you know are in a culture that is
dominated by the left
despite Chain Coast ins evidence list
propositions to the contrary the fact is
that the mainstream American media
culture is dominated by the left it's
not dominated by people like me okay
Taylor wire has become a very big site
thank God but it is not a big site in
comparison to places like Huffington
Post and the fact is the left still
dominates in the media conversation and
for a gen Koston to deny that infer to
suggest that those of us on the right
are merely in the pandering business is
to demonstrate her own ignorance you
want to know who is in the pandering
business somebody who is hailed by the
left is a moral hero
is Jimmy Kimmel so Jimmy Kimmel was held
for the past three four or five weeks
ever really since the Obamacare attempt
by a by the senator from uh what's the
name of the senator who was on his show
and in case I can't remember the name of
the senator for sub bill Cassidy Cassidy
in any case the the Jimmy Kimmel did a
whole rant about Bill Cassidy and
Obamacare how terrible it would be if
Obamacare were repealed it was evidence
list it was fact free I did an entire
rebuttal of it here on the show that
went viral and Jimmy Kimmel has been
hailed as a moral leader because he
spoke out on gun control and because he
spoke out on health care and he accepted
this mantle he obviously thinks that he
has a voice in this he's not just a
comedian he is a voice in this and as a
citizen he feels the necessity to use
his platform now he has every right to
do that right he has every right to do
this this whole thing what I said was
when Jimmy Kimmel did this know this
routine that he was the moral arbiter
for the country and he posed himself as
that right he said things like you're
immoral if you disagree with me this was
the implication of his of his Las Vegas
rant and if you disagreed with him you
were immoral you want people to die
because you're being paid off by the gun
lobby we went through it in detail here
on the show you know you pose yourself
as the moral voice of the country
I said who died and made Jimmy Kimmel
the moral arbiter well because that went
viral Jimmy Kimmel without responding to
me by name responded to me directly on
one of the sunday shows here was Jimmy
Kimmel responding and I want you to know
who do you think is pandering here who
do you think is pandering am i pandering
for standing up for a perspective that I
have held my entire political career
have spoken out for openly and honestly
for 15 16 17 years or am 33 so I'm doing
this since I was 17 so 16 years right
say you know is it is it me am I the one
pandering when I say things that I think
are true to the right and to the left
or is it Jimmy Kimmel because I'm gonna
show you a clip of Jimmy Kimmel in which
he openly acknowledges that he's
basically pandering and he doesn't
really care here's Jimmy Kimmel you've
heard there's one conservative
commentator in particular who says who
made Jimmy Kimmel the moral arbiter I'm
not I mean yeah I agree with them I'm
nobody's moral arbiter I mean you don't
have to watch the show you don't have to
listen to what I say like three years
ago I was
equally liked by Republicans and
Democrats and Republican numbers went
down like 30 percent or whatever and you
know as a talk show host that's not
ideal but I did I would do it again in a
heartbeat so you don't mind if
Republicans turn off your show they're
not watching anymore I don't say I don't
mind I mean I'd love for everyone I want
everyone with the television to watch
the show but if they're so turned off by
my opinion on health care and gun
violence then I don't know I probably
wouldn't want to have a conversation
with them anyway okay so it's that last
part that's but that's the telling part
so number one when he says he didn't
appoint himself a moral arbiter I'm glad
I wish the media would stop a point to
me a moral arbiter them and I wish that
he would stop talking in these
passionate moral tones about everyone
who disagreeing disagrees with him being
the Antichrist like that would be nice
if he would if he would cut that out
then if he's not the moral Arbour than
he should stop posing as one and that
final comment is the one where I say
he's pandering that final one where he
says if people disagree with me so much
on these topics that they just turn off
the TV then I wouldn't want to have a
conversation with them anyway well if
somebody said that to me right if
somebody said they're a bunch of people
who are turned off by a rhetoric what do
you what do you say about that I would
say some of the same things that Jimmy
Kimmel said right I would say listen
they have a right to watch the show
they've right not to watch the show but
I'd say maybe they should listen to my
perspective and all this into theirs and
we can have a discussion I say this in
every speech in every speech I say this
okay I always say that I want the
conversation to take place I want more
people on the left to listen and I want
to hear their ideas too so we can go
back and forth on this okay it's Jimmy
Kimmel saying basically if you don't
want to watch the show so long see ya
right dad that is not the voice of
somebody who wants to convince that is
somebody that's the voice of somebody
who wants to pander so Jen coats one if
Jen Koston wants to write a piece I'm
talking about quote-unquote hollow moral
bravery then maybe she ought to start
with the person who I'm not saying Jimmy
Kimmel appointed himself moral arbiter
except that he sort of did on his show
I'm saying the media appointed him moral
arbiter and he seemed happy to accept
that and happy to revel in it until the
point where I called him out at which
point he immediately backtracked so I'm
glad he's backtracking
I'm glad Jimmy Kimmel doesn't think of
himself as a moral arbiter if Jimmy
Kimmel really wants to debate these
issues and have
honest conversation about them I'm more
than happy to come on his show and I'm
more than happy to have him on mine I
don't think that's going to happen okay
so I want to talk about Harvey Weinstein
because this has been the brewing
scandal for a long time here but before
I get to that I first want to say thank
you to our sponsors over at my Patriot
supply so right now look at this fire in
Northern California we've seen so many
natural disasters really awful in the
past few weeks we've seen this natural
disaster in in Northern California we've
seen hurricanes in Puerto Rico we see a
hurricane in Texas we saw a hurricane in
Florida we've seen a huge fire actually
pretty close to us out here off the
2-ton these natural disasters mean that
there are going to be times hopefully
not but there may be times in your life
when you have to rely on whatever food
is in your house and maybe didn't go to
the grocery store that week or maybe
your fridge is down because there was a
power outage well that's why you need
some food that is going to take you
through those hard times from our
friends over at my Patriot supply this
week you can get their 72-hour emergency
food kit for just $17 and 76 cents
seventeen dollars and 76 cents for their
72-hour emergency food kit that includes
free shipping order now at eight eight
eight eight oh three fourteen thirteen
eight eight eight eight oh three 14 13
or online and prepare with been calm
again that's prepare with been calm and
yet 72 hours emergency food kit so
you're prepared for any emergency
because most emergencies will be over in
3 days 17 dollars and 76 cents with that
special low price there's a limit of 4
per order limit of 4 per order my
Patriot supply believes in old-fashioned
values Plus apparently their food tastes
really good I've been told by that by
people around the office we did a taste
test in everything join me in their
mission to build a more prepared country
make that call today eight eight eight
eight oh three fourteen thirteen that's
eight eight eight eight oh three
fourteen thirteen or go to prepare with
been calm again that's prepare with been
calm okay let's talk about Harvey
Weinstein so I've lived my entire life
in Hollywood I grew up in Hollywood my
mom works in Hollywood I have met Harvey
Weinstein I met him one time I was at
the four seasons having breakfast with a
friend of mine named David suiza who's
the editor over at the LA Jewish Journal
and David introduced me to Harvey
Weinstein wise he was a jerk but he did
not sexually harass me which apparently
makes me the only person in 300-mile
radius he did not sexually harass so
for what that is worth in any case one
Scene now obviously they're saying there
are hundreds of cases in which he
sexually assaulted her ass to rape
people so that is is shocking but not
surprising the reason I say it's
shocking but not surprising is that this
has long been a part of Hollywood
culture to pretend otherwise is just
foolish and unlike in for example the
Catholic Church which is against these
things
this has always been a long if not
celebrated then winked at nodded at
grinned at laughed at part of Hollywood
culture it has been the casting culture
has been casting couch
has been part of Hollywood culture since
the very beginning and to pretend
otherwise is just to let Hollywood off
the hook for a perspective on human
sexuality that is seriously perverse and
leads to really dire consequences the
reason the left wants to ignore this of
course is because the Hollywood view of
human sexuality that allowed for this
sort of misbehavior and evil to accrue
and and occur for literally decades on
end is something that the left sort of
holds in high regard and that is the
transactional nature of sex so let's
talk a little bit about the casting
couch for just a second so first of all
here's a little bit of Hollywood history
it was built on sexual peccadilloes and
in particular on the casting couch here
is a long list of people who are
involved in using the so-called casting
couch for those who don't know the
phrase casting couch means that there's
a director he has to cast a part in his
film and so he'll go to a hot star lit
or upcoming starlet who has ambitions
and say to her you want a shot at this
role you want a screen test darlin get
down on that couch right that's what the
casting couch meant okay here are some
of the people who engaged in lui be
mayor right the founder of MGM
apparently he sexually assaulted teenage
Judy Garland they're stories about him
with Judy Garland on his lap when she
was 16 years old and him final and her
breasts okay so this goes back a long
time Arthur freed legendary producer
allegedly exposed himself to Shirley
Temple when she was 11 years old she
wrote that in her memoir harry cohn a
guy so hated in hollywood that there was
an old joke that used to go around about
harry cohn that his funeral would be the
most well attended event in the history
of Hollywood cuz everyone
it was dead but harry cohn had a long
history of sexual abuse apparently
Darryl zanuck reportedly solicited
prospective starlets on a routine basis
Howard Hughes not only slept with
starlets consensually but apparently had
a casting couch himself and this is a
running joke in Hollywood for years okay
it's a part of the movies all about evil
won Best Picture in 1950 it's a terrific
film I've recommended it here on the on
the on the actual show this joke
involves Marilyn Monroe so you're gonna
see here a very very young Marilyn
Monroe this is one of Marilyn Monroe's
first screen roles in which she had a
speaking role anyway and she plays a an
up-and-coming woman who's attempting to
break into the theater she's a bit part
George Sanders is is playing a theater
critic named Addison to Wed and he's
been squiring Monroe's character around
basically she's sleeping with him so
that he will Squire her around town and
then he passes her off to the producers
right the way that he's going to pass
her off to the producers is have her
essentially uses a sexual object by the
producers in order to solicit depart
there's an open there's an open part of
the film right I mean this is part of
the joke here it is from the film then
you too must have a long talk I'm afraid
mr. DeWitt would find me boring before
too long you won't bore him honey
you won't even get a chance to talk
Claudia come here
you see that man that's max Fabian the
producer now don't do yourself some good
why do they always look like unhappy
rabbits because that's what they are I'm
gonna make him happier all I want is a
drink
leave it I'll get one thank you the
pretty baby well done I can see your
career rising at least like the Sun okay
and then she ends up getting another
shoe but not getting the pardon then he
said he asks Addison DeWitt for his
advice he says go try the same thing in
Hollywood okay this is in the New York
theatre circles this has always been a
part of Hollywood it's always been a
disgusting horrible part of Hollywood to
pretend otherwise is to ignore reality
okay Harvey Weinstein is the worst
example of what happens in Hollywood but
it is ridiculous to suggest he's the
only example of this happening in
Hollywood okay there are a number of
starlets who have talked about this over
time I'm talking about virtually all of
the major ones have talked about Joan
Collins talked about Marilyn Monroe
described the town as being fishy she
said that this is from her autobiography
she said producers treated Hollywood
quote like an overcrowded brothel hey a
movie that many more people have seen
than All About Eve although I'll about
Eva's is a great movie The Godfather
this is part of the plot don't you
remember in The Godfather right Jack
Woltz you remember the guy who ends up
with the horse head in his bed do you
remember the conversation that leads to
the horse head in his bed in The
Godfather
it's Jack Woltz this famous Hollywood
producer been sitting with Tom Hagen and
he says to him and this is direct quote
Johnny Fontane never gets that part
right Johnny Fontane ruined one of
Walt's International's most valuable
protegees I was gonna make her a big
star and let me be even more Frank just
to show you that I'm not a hard-hearted
man that's not all dollars and cents she
was beautiful she was young she was
innocent she was the greatest piece of
ass I've ever had right that's in The
Godfather
everyone knew in Hollywood about this
for decades it's still going on in
Hollywood right now it's still going on
in Hollywood right now okay power means
that power combined with transactional
sex leads to sexual abuse okay power
plus transactional sex leads to sexual
abuse not just for women who are openly
raped and their consent violated but for
women who are essentially forced into
the position of having to sleep with
guys they don't want to sleep with in
order to make their way to the top that
system has been in place for a hundred
years in Hollywood and that's not a
justification for the system folks this
is me ripping on Hollywood's morality
this is me ripping on the transactional
nature of sex and beauty in Hollywood
this has been true forever famous
actresses like Ellen Barkin she comes
down she says that Harvey Weinstein's
evil that everyone knew about them for
years but rich famous actors and
actresses said nothing okay where were
you once you became rich and famous
wasn't it incumbent on you to out these
people if you actually want to change
the system you can't wait till Harvey
Weinstein gets out and then you tell
your Horror Story about Harvey Weinstein
you want to talk about hollow bravery to
me that's how low bravery because now
Harvey Weinstein's already outed you
want actual bravery tell us who the bad
guys are so that we can root them out if
you want to change the system you have
to get rid of the bad guys and the only
people who are capable of making that
move are people who are already the
stars
they're the people who are already the
stars because if you're up-and-coming if
you're 18
you're trying to get a job in Hollywood
you're trying to make your way it's sort
of like the deal that a lot of baseball
players made with steroids in the early
2000s right you can either languish in
triple-a or you can take the steroids
and go for the millions of dollars is
that an immoral decision yeah it's an
immoral decision is didn't understand
but one it's also an understandable
decision the same thing happens to be
true with a lot of these young Hollywood
actresses and actors who come to
Hollywood looking for a career and the
difference between them being Tom Hanks
and them being a guy working at the
coffee bean is what they're willing to
do in a bedroom with a producer the only
way that that system gets broken is if
the people who are already stars
dedicate themselves to rooting this out
and that means naming names because bad
people will continue to do bad things so
long as they have these jobs names have
to be named hey then back to the
transactional sex point again men in
power have always used sex for
transactional purposes and this doesn't
they just exist in Hollywood this is
existed in public schools that exists in
churches and synagogues it exists in in
politics obviously Bill Clinton comes to
mind right this is what Bill Clinton
said to Kathleen Willey all of this it
has been happening for years but it only
stops when the public shows that they
are not willing to accept the
transactional nature of sex that sex
means
more than just I'm trading sex for a
part I'm trading sex for a role I'm
trading sex with power for power there
is a value to sex beyond the the
ever-present physical stimulus it is
more than just shaking hands so long as
society treats sex that way it's gonna
be very difficult to curb these impulses
it's gonna make it harder to curb these
impulses either sex means something or
it doesn't if sex is just a handshake
well then a handshake can close a
business deal but if sex is more than
that then we ought to look askance at
the casting couch even if the women are
consenting to be on it because that sort
of consent is not real consent in my
view that sort of consent is is a power
relationship you know this is where I'm
more feminist than a lot of people on
both the right and the left that sort of
power relationship is an exploitation of
women in society needs to disapprove of
this has this can it be done sure
societies did in the past
in fact society so disapproved of the
Hollywood treatment of sex in the 1920s
that the Catholic Legion of decency led
a boycott against Hollywood and that
boycott led Hollywood to actually
reflect these in the values of the time
in its own films they they had a
voluntary thing called the Hays Code the
Hays Code existed from the 1930s to the
1960s and that's why you have all of
these movies where everyone will every
kiss his closed mouth where there are no
sex scenes why from 1930s in the 1960s
you don't see people in bed together why
men and women sleep in separate beds all
of that is a reflection of the Hays Code
did the Hays Code go too far in some
ways yeah I think it did but was it a
reflection of the fact that the American
people were not willing to go along with
Hollywood's view of sex yes and the
American people have to not be willing
to go along with that view of sex and
they have to extend a better more
sanctified view of sex into their own
lives as well so I think that that's
that that's what I have to say about
Harvey Weinstein I think also by the way
that every community should look to its
own here I do think that every community
should look to its its own issues with
regard to sexual power dynamics and see
whether they are upholding standards of
their communities or whether they are
undermining those standards this again I
think is the difference between churches
and synagogues in Hollywood I think as I
showed you in this movie this has always
been an openly accepted part of
Hollywood culture it was never an openly
accepted part of church culture which is
why it's so ridiculous that the media
have decided to make you know every time
there's a sexual scandal in the Catholic
Church the media decided that they're
gonna make this about priests being
celibate when there's a sexual scandal
in Hollywood where sex scandals are the
rule not the exception then it's well
why are we making a big deal about
Hollywood this happens everywhere
because in one area it's endemic to the
culture and celebrated in the culture
and then one it is abhorred okay I'm
going to talk a little bit about Hillary
Clinton's response to this in just a
second but first I want to say thank you
to our sponsors over at Skillshare so
Skillshare is the best way to bulk up
your resume if you're looking to get a
leg up at work if you are looking to
constantly be adding to your skill set I
listen I encourage everyone to do this
if you're looking to take your career to
the next level then you need to go over
to Skillshare comm and check it out they
have over three million members and more
than 17,000 classes it is the Netflix
for online learning you can take classes
in graphic design DSL DSLR photography
social media marketing digital
illustration they're taught by industry
experts these classes and experienced
professionals they are perfect if you're
looking to build your career or start
the side business of your dreams right
now I've taken a couple of their courses
I famously took one in watercolours yes
seriously cuz I have to calm down in the
evenings but now I'm also taking one in
social media marketing skill share comm
is the best way to learn a new skill and
make yourself more competitive in the
job market you can't sit there with the
same skill set and hope that you're
gonna grow you need to constantly be
getting better that's how your pay goes
up that's how your job gets better skill
share is giving my listeners right now a
one-month free trial unlimited access to
over 17,000 classes go right now to
Skillshare comm slash Shapiro and when
you use that slash up here you get a
free month today again in skill shared
comm slash up hero skills shared comm
slash Shapiro to start that free month
today and again you get that free month
17,000 classes once you start it you're
not gonna want to stop because learning
and growing is is the best way to ensure
future employment and future wage growth
okay so Hillary Clinton I think is a
perfect example of somebody who has
accepted the the leftist view of of sex
and power and yet proclaims that she
does and this is why you see people like
me saying that Hollywood is full of
hypocrisy by the way this is not to let
up on the hypocrisy of people who made
light of Donald Trump's language with
regard to this this is why I was I
surprised by Trump I was not surprised
by Trump in the in the P in the P word
of grabbing video
I was not surprised by that because I
don't think Trump is conservative I
think Trump is Hollywood I think Trump
is New York and Hollywood right Trump
looks more at home in All About Eve than
he does in the Bible Belt
so his sort of ethics with regard to sex
are obviously Hollywood FX with regard
to sex so I wasn't really surprised by
that but people who excused it for Trump
and then made excute and then and then
go after Weinstein or who made excuses
for Weinstein for years and then went
after Trump they're all hypocrites
anyway here is one of those hypocrites
Hillary Clinton who is going after Trump
while basically ignoring the fact that
there is someone whose last name rhymes
with glint in' who she is married to who
engaged in precisely the same sorts of
activities i didn't know but everyone
knew rumors about i'm not specific cases
but well I knew that Harvey Weinstein
apparently in his circle was a little
bit you know well all I can tell you is
that I did not hear those things look we
just elected a person who admitted
sexual assault to the presidency so
there's a lot of other issues that are
swirling around these kinds of behaviors
that need to be addressed and I think
it's important that we stay focused and
shine a bright spotlight and try to get
people to understand how damaging this
is and the women coming forward is the
only way that that story will be told
okay the women coming forward is the
only one that story is going to be told
hmm Juanita Broderick Kathleen Willey
Monica Lewinsky all bubbleheads all
Liars according to Hillary Clinton it's
so funny the left is very upset if you
say this about Hillary Clinton but
Hillary does not have any credibility to
speak on this issue whatsoever
she did participate in covering up her
husband's peccadilloes and to pretend
otherwise is ignorant and then of course
you blame sexism endemic to society okay
if Hillary Clinton really cared about
this stuff
she would have outed her husband long
ago but she is a perfect example of
somebody who married to power in order
and and overlooked this sort of behavior
in order to get away with it this is you
wonder why the right just why the right
was willing to quote/unquote overlook
Trump it's one of the reasons the right
was willing to overlook Trump is because
he was running against Hillary Clinton
who was part of the problem as well
sexism and misogyny are endemic in our
society and I do try to take readers on
a journey with me and obviously I use
Bill's story and Barack story to tell
how galvanizing you know they were
because people immediately saw this arc
of you know from you know poverty in
Hope Arkansas you know from a biracial
family in Hawaii how really impressive
and exciting their stories were I'm a
middle-class girl from the middle of the
country and so I always struggled with
like okay so what's my story and it
suddenly dawned on me that I was the
beneficiary of these radical changes in
you know women's rights and
opportunities that Hillary Clinton is
the anti feminist when it comes to this
understand something about feminism okay
originally feminism then you stop it
there originally feminism was designed
against things like the casting couch
feminism was designed against the madman
theory that women had to go to bed with
their bosses in order to progress in the
company that's what feminism was founded
upon Hillary Clinton made excuses for
her husband married into power and then
used that power for her own benefit this
is part of the leftist culture again
you can't proclaim that you can proclaim
that Harvey Weinstein is an absolute
piece of crap under all circumstances
there are no reservations about that but
you cannot proclaim that the culture
that created Harvey Weinstein has
nothing to do with the promulgation of
many more people like Harvey Weinstein
in Hollywood I mean look at Twitter
right now and what you're gonna see is a
bunch of Hollywood stars who condemned
Harvey Weinstein and then five seconds
later there's some woman on Twitter who
says I was at a Golden Globes party five
seconds ago and Ben Affleck was grabbing
my ass like really this happened on
Twitter this is all happening on Twitter
in real time because this is part of the
culture out here it is and that's part
of a broader left-wing culture that is a
problem there are lots of problems in
right-wing culture too and I'm happy to
talk about those when those arise the
the problems of sexual harassment at Fox
News I should have talked more about it
at the time but the but the reality is
that what we are watching right now is
much more endemic to the culture of
Hollywood than it is at Fox News it
wasn't like Fox News they were releasing
shows making jokes about sexual assault
or if they were I missed it in any case
I want to talk about some moves that
President Trump made while I was out of
town but first you're going to have to
go over to Daley wire right now and
subscribe so for $9.99 a month you can
get your subscriptions who daily
wire.com that ensures that you get my
show live it means that we're a video
show not just an audio show we have a
brand new camera that slides back and
forth we have lots of special tools and
gadgets that make the show really fun to
watch and you can watch the rest of the
show live not just on Facebook or
YouTube and you can do that by going to
daily wired I can't be part of our
mailbag on Fridays we do have a mailbag
this week which will be very exciting we
have a full week of broadcast planned
yay plus Andrew Clavin the show is
coming up at 10:30 plus michael Moses
Show is coming up at 12:30 so lots to
talk about you can watch all of those
show live you can you can interact with
the host plus you can ask mailbag
questions to people like me and Andrew
Clavin we have this new series called
the conversation I just did one about
two and a half weeks ago where I
answered questions only from our
subscribers so if you want your question
answered that is the best way to get
your question answered and your life
fixed our second episode of the
conversation is coming up on Tuesday
tomorrow right at 5:00 yes tomorrow okay
tomorrow at 5:00 p.m. Eastern 2 p.m.
Pacific featuring Andrew Klavan hosted
by another one of our brand new
employees Alicia Krauss all of the
mysteries of the universe will be solved
all of your life's questions will be
answered we're gonna livestream on both
daily wire Facebook page and the YouTube
channel everyone can watch but only
subscribers can ask the questions and by
the way you should subscribe anyway and
help support us because we just brought
on tremendous new people like Alicia
Krauss we just brought on columnist Matt
Walsh hey coming over from the blaze
which is really exciting we're excited
to welcome Matt Walsh to daily wire as
well so check it out at daily wire if
you're on the annual subscription you
get this the very finest in all beverage
of vessels the leftist years hot or cold
mug you can enjoy those years at any
temperature or any other liquid that you
choose to consume daily wire hot or cold
mug you get that when leftist here's how
to called mug when you get the annual
subscription for $99 a year or listen
later for free at iTunes or SoundCloud
you can listen to the whole show for
free over at YouTube when you subscribe
we are they are the largest and
fastest-growing conservative podcast in
the nation
[Music]
you
okay now it's time for me to bust a few
myths so over the last week President
Trump has taken a bunch of actions that
are actually quite good or don't do much
and the left is going nuts over them so
let's start with this thing that
President Trump is somehow going to
cause the collapse of Obamacare because
he's so evil and so terrible so Chris
Murphy from Connecticut ever someone who
is moderate and and well reasoned in his
stances loses his mind his head explodes
actually on television like the end of
Kingsman and he explains that Trump is
putting a gun to the head of
constituents by defunding some of the
Obamacare exchanges he is literally
setting the entire healthcare system on
fire just because the president is upset
that the United States Congress won't
pass a repeal bill he is not literally
setting the entire healthcare system on
fire the health care system is abstract
it'd be very difficult for him to do so
unless he headed on over to Health and
Human Services and started a fire in a
broom closet somewhere
you can't literally set things on fire
that are not physical commodities so in
any case let's let's talk about what
President Trump actually did on health
care hey IVA Kroy is sort of the go-to
expert with regard to health care
regulations and law it's pretty complex
but I will use avec Roy's framework here
because I think this is exactly right so
here is what he says he says on Thursday
President Trump issued an executive
order covering three areas one allowing
small businesses to pull together to
purchase health insurance to restoring
the ability of individuals to buy short
term plans exempt from some Obamacare
rules and three examining ways to make
employer funded health savings accounts
more flexible the Left says that this is
going to destroy the health care system
and then he said that he was going to
stop dispersing cost-sharing subsidies
until Congress appropriates the funds
for them okay the last one is the one
that he's talking about that no longer
the federal government just going to
willy-nilly decide to fund Obamacare
exchanges that is correct because it is
illegal when Obama did it it was illegal
Obama doing it was in violation of Obama
care law Obama decided he didn't care
and did it anyway
Trump threw it back to Congress if
Congress wants to use the Obama care
subsidies as leverage to make changes to
Obamacare then they damn well should
that would make a lot of sense Trump
didn't do anything wrong there as far as
these other changes allowing small
businesses to pull together to pelipper
health insurance the idea here is that
supposedly this will exclude certain
small businesses that basically the way
it works right now is that you are not
allowed to discriminate under Obamacare
based on previous health history at
least with regard to large businesses so
small businesses will be forced to small
businesses will be forced to be
discriminated against here's here's the
way that that advic where I puts it he
basically says the idea of Association
health the health plans has been around
for a long time george w bush included
them in his 2007 health reform proposal
the idea is that individuals could get
insurance from voluntary associations
like the Sierra Club or a church group
the trump executive order claims to
legalize Association health plans but
actually it doesn't even do that it
allows small businesses but not
voluntary associations to pool together
to buy insurance in bulk in fact the
order is even more modest than that
small businesses already have the
ability to pool together instead the
employee instead the likely impact of
this part of the executive order is
minimal to zero so basically it has no
impact restoring the ability of
individuals to buy short-term plans
again that's good examining ways to make
employer funded health savings accounts
more flexible that too is good but the
left imposes all of these things because
it wants to force people into health
insurance through Obamacare other things
that Trump did that were good over the
weekend or over the last week he refused
to recertify the morontia but he's not
withdraw from the Iran deal I think this
is a mistake
I think refusing to recertify the Iran
deal is correct I think you should just
withdraw from it so the idea was that he
sort of split the baby there were there
were three choices one was recertified
the Iran deal Iran is in compliance with
the Iran deal because the Iran deal was
specifically written so it's almost
impossible for Iran not to be in
compliance with the Iran deal that was
why it was such a bad deal to begin with
which is why Trump should just get out
of it instead Trump is saying I'm not
going to recertify because the deal is
bad we're gonna set some new conditions
and if Iran doesn't fulfill those
conditions then we'll impose sanctions
okay better than nothing for sure it is
splitting the baby a little bit but
Trump statements on this were exactly
correct here is Trump talking about how
Iran is a fanatical regime
today I am announcing our strategy along
with several major steps we are taking
to confront the Iranian regime's hostile
actions and to ensure that Iran never
and I mean never acquires
a nuclear weapon our policy is based on
a clear-eyed assessment of the Iranian
dictatorship okay we can stop it there
this was good stuff from Trump this is
excellent Trump other excellent Trump he
would through from UNESCO UNESCO is one
of the world's most garbage
organizations that is the UN the UN
Educational Scientific and Cultural
Organization it has never been
educational scientific or cultural it's
basically been in Israel bashing seminar
in 2011 they declared that the Church of
the Noah 2012 they declared the Church
of the Nativity was a world heritage
site in danger which is not true
and then they claimed that the Western
Wall was not a Jewish site which is
insane they referred to the Temple Mount
as the al-aqsa mosque plaza they called
the Wailing Wall the Barak Plaza and
they called Israel the occupying power
in Jerusalem the United States basically
said we're done here and they withdrew
from UNESCO it is my view that we should
withdraw entirely from the United
Nations which is a stupid organization
but that would require a little bit more
time for me to explain okay so we really
don't have much time for things I like
and things I hate so I'll skip things I
like today and we will do just one thing
that I hate today and that is David
Brooks from The New York Times so David
Brooks from the New York Times the
so-called conservative at the New York
Times he's not conservative he once said
that he likes Barack Obama he infamously
said that he likes Barack Obama because
he could tell by the crease in his pants
that he was his kind of guy which I
don't make a habit of staring at creases
in other dudes pants it's just weird but
in any case that was his tank here is
David Brooks from the New York Times
explaining that the real reason that
Trump has been bad on Puerto Rico is
because the Puerto Ricans are brown
there's been a lack of there's where
there was total graciousness toward
Texas and graciousness toward Florida
but he's incapable of showing any
compassion and graciousness toward
people who were just trying to find
drinking water in Puerto Rico and so the
lesson is is the lesson that we're all
going to draw from that that the people
in Puerto Rico don't look like a lot of
the people in Texas and
I think that's that's probably a pretty
fair judgement okay so you know no and
here's the proof that no here's a Puerto
Rican delegate yesterday saying Trump
gave us everything we asked for again
you sort of have to disconnect Trump
being stupid on Twitter from what Trump
is actually done in Puerto Rico again
the evidence is at best mixed on Puerto
Rico but I see very little evidence that
Trump was willfully withholding aid from
Puerto Rico because they look more Brown
than people in Texas especially is it by
the way Texas had a heavy Hispanic
population inside I believe by
percentage the second heaviest Hispanic
population in the nation after
California I believe it in any case here
is here is this Puerto Rican delegate
explaining I will tell you that the
president everything he'd the president
said that he was going to send an island
it's getting there
the resources are there the help is
there he instructed all his cabinet
members to treat pro Rico as a state in
terms of this hurricane plenty of
reasons to criticize President Trump and
I am more than willing to do so when he
does something wrong but he jumped to
conclusions in order to target people
it's got to stop okay guys evidence
evidence evidence evidence that holds
true for Jane Koston and that should
also hold true for David Brooks over at
the New York Times as it should hold
true for me when I make a claim we
should all have the same you know basis
evidence for the claims we make okay we
will be back here tomorrow because we're
not on vacation anymore so fear not we
will be back here tomorrow to organize
all of the day's myriad events I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]